[Music]
where you from still water who's the
last drilling company you work for ita
why'd you quit
operator dropped the rig we stacked i
got laid off six months ago what are you
doing now
i work construction
but it's been slow since the rig's been
down
i've been doing cleanup after that
tornado by shawnee
getting after it
[Music]
hey sir
let me finish this page
one more page
thank you for this food and for all that
is good in this world
keep allison in your watchful eye amen
amen
you get hired out yet
nope
[Music]
i had an interview this morning
got a call from your mother a few days
ago
she moved to tampa she asked for money
or some [ __ ]
no
she asked about you
you should call her sometime
i got enough i'm dealing with here
did you pick up my car registration
yeah
a lot at home spent all morning waiting
for it
got it online
everything's online can't get a real
human being if you tried
didn't stop him from charging me 23
i'll pay it
that's not what i meant
i know
there's a bag of things by the front
door for you to take
and an envelope of photos and on her
desk those are important
[Music]
[Music]
okay you have two stopovers the first in
atlanta the second in frankfurt you're
getting 22.
[Music]
good
because
[Music]
i just need your signature please
you are with us for two weeks yes ma'am
thanks
here's your key room 156.
thank you man
welcome back mr baker
is
[Music]
[Music]
hey
hey y'all not keeping it down trying to
sleep
the music
no no no english no speaking
good night
[Music]
baker
[Music]
[Music]
baker
answer
[Music]
[Applause]
hey baby girl hey dad
you look good
how's the fight
okay
you doing all right
i'm okay yeah good
good you got some laundry for me
yeah something i'll get it done
they gave us two more visiting days the
next one's uh friday 2 p.m
that's graham
she's good
still got the oxygen tank
still got plenty of opinions
miss her
she bought you everything you wanted uh
you got your extra pair of socks and uh
good new pair of sneakers
thanks
uh graham said that she was giving you
some photos for me
oh [ __ ] i forgot him i'll just bring him
next time no i mean i forgot him at home
and steal water
sorry
doesn't matter
i got you a cowboy sweatshirt the
airport they're gonna be good this year
they got this big old tight end out of
guthrie
it takes about three guys to bring him
down he's gonna go pro for sure
cool
you still work in the library
no i quit
um dad i need you to do something
i need you to get that to the park make
sure she reads it okay what is it
it's a letter just give it to her
the dress is on the envelope okay yeah
okay
but
are you good good
please
i'll do it today
i'll make sure she reads it
[Music]
monica pray but
you're done
thank you lord for bringing us together
on this blessed day and thank you for
keeping watchful eye on alison
mr baker
i'm sorry you had to wait but metroback
is not coming back to the office today
come back tomorrow then thank you man mr
baker she's in court all week
why don't you give me a letter and i
will make sure she gets it can't do that
thank you man as you wish
right
you locked out
key you got a key
uh uh nope
come on let's go get it
come on i'm gonna get you a new key
bill
bill
dean
closer
what's your name
hmm you
may yeah
maya that's nice
sequoia
[Music]
eagle bald eagle america
yeah i got a skull with a knife going
through it
thank you man
you